it is so good to see you Keith yeah we
usually have to wait for a special
occasion
well actually I have a little surprise I
got engaged
[Laughter]
yes Wow
gratulations little bro haha engaged
kind of a big deal more for me I guess
doesn't that means yes well she got a
maid Stephanie marriage is a wonderful
journey 50% in the divorce
sorry brown them's just the facts I will
keep that in mind thank you you got a
photo oh yeah aka does she exist there
we go
oh she's beautiful
let me get eyes on this everybody else
already had great lighting
airbrush I know she kinda looks like
that one model on The Price is Right yes
that's her the price is right Clyde
that's your show shut up mom no it's not
Oh Stephanie people always underbid on
her showcases not the best presenter
where's the wedding Oh
in Hawaii Oh
Mele Kalikimaka she ever been married
before
uh no so she says ex-boyfriends you got
one of course
sloppy seconds at least right dad Keith
she sounds wonderful shut up MA silence
from you okay you're cut off from
talking you know what Clive I really
don't appreciate the way that you're
talking to mom yes yes the prodigal son
has returned you know what you want to
go let's go
cuz I've been here the last 15 years
taking care of mom and dad believin
trouncing all over the world and why
come back here criticize me for how I
treat no I actually came here to ask you
if he would do me the honor of being my
best man
I know that we have had our differences
but you're my older brother
[Music]
we'll pay for your room and we're also
gonna rent you a car
and we'll pay to fly you out there first
gloves well we can't afford first class
well you're dead to me a meeting of it
in Rome
well that that went better than expected
I think so
you